[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى هذه اللقطات من فلوريدا لمقر اقامه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الذي
من المرتقب وامثله امام المحكمه في
نيويورك بعد غد الثلاثاء
ومنها السنكي هذه الصور المباشره
وهذه اللقطات التي تاتي مع ترقب خروج
نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه هناك
وهذه اللقطات التي تاتيكم من مكه المكرمه
واجواء الحرم في شهر رمضان بعيده انتهاء
الصلاه التراويح
تقبل الله صيامكم وقيامكم وهذه الصور الان
مباشره
من القدس المحتله بمواجهه بين قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه التي اقتحمت المصلى
القبلي في المسجد الاقصى واخلته من
المعتكفين
[موسيقى]
سنكون في المتابعه مع هذا الموضوع خلال
الحصاد لان في مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قرار جدلي جديد لحكومه نتنياهو وسط
انتقادات حاده اقرار انشاء الحرس الوطني
تحت اشراف وزير الامن القومي
المعارضه تحذر من التداعيات وتصف الحرس
بجيش من البلطجيه وتاكيد الحكومي بتمرير
التعديلات القضائيه المؤجله في مايو
المقبل
غدا تغارات استهدفت مواقع في حمص وسط
سوريا اسرائيل تعلن اسقاط طائره مسيره
تسللت من الاجواء السوريه فهران تعلن مقتل
ضابط ثاني في الحرس الثوري في غاره في
دمشق وتتوعد اسرائيل بالرد ووزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول ان بلاده تعمل على اخراج
ايران وحزب الله اللبناني من سوريا
لانتاج النفط ابتداء من شهر مايو واشنطن
تصف القرار بغير المنطقي وتؤكد مواصلتها
العمل مع باقي المنتجين لضمان استمرار
انخفاض الاسعار
لفرد السيطره على باخمت والقوه الاوكرانيه
تشن هجوما مضادا في المدينه
في الداخل الروسي تفجير في مقهى
يستهدف مراسلا حربيا
كان يجري اتصالا مباشرا بلابروف ويطلب
الافراج الفوري عن صحفي امريكي متهم
بالتجسس
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المشهد المحتدم بين حكومه
نتنياهو والمعارضه وذلك على خلفيه انشاء
الحرس الوطني الذي سيلحق بوزير الامن
القومي اتمار ضمن صفقه بينه وبين نتنياهو
مقابل تاجيل تمرير الاصلاحات القضائيه
المعارضه وصفت التشكيله المزمعه بانه
ميليشيا وجيش من البلطجيه بينما تقول
الحكومه انه سيخصص لاحداث واضطرابات كالتي
وقعت قبل عامين خلال الحرب مع غزه وهو
اقرب الى التلميح بانها ستكون موجهه
للفلسطينيين حصرا
لاستطلاعه ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل ستنجح حكومه
نتنياهو في اتمام انشاء ما يعرف بالحرس
الوطني وتجاوز عقبه الاحتجاجات
43% قالوا انها ستنجح في تمريره بينما راى
57% ان حكومه نتنياهو لن تستطيع ذلك ولن
تتجاوز عقبه الاحتجاجات هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الذي
يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع ترقب توجه ترامب الى محكمه نيويورك بعد
غدنا الثلاثاء استقطاب سياسي في الشارع
الامريكي ومخاوف امنيه
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلنت الحكومه الاسرائيليه انشاء
الحرس الوطني في وزاره الامن القومي وقالت
ان صلاحيات الحرس الوطني ستناقش من قبل
لجنه مهنيه من جميع القوى الامنيه في
الدوله واضافت الحكومه في تغريده ان الحرس
الوطني سيتعامل مع حالات الطوارئ الوطنيه
مثل الاضطرابات اثناء عمليه حارس الاسوار
وكانت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قالت ان
الحكومه توافقت على اقتطاع واحد ونصف في
المئه من ميزانيات الوزارات وذلك لتمويل
انشاء الحرس
في الاثناء نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن
وزيره النقل في حكومه نتنياهو قولها الى
الحكومه ستستانف العمل على مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه بعد عيد الاستقلال
مباشره حسب تعبيرها وكان نتنياهو اعلن
وقفا المداولات بشان مشروع التعديلات على
وقع مظاهرات مناويه للحكومه
كيان مسلح خاص بل هي ميليشيا تلك التي
اعلنت حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو انشائها
ولتمويل قوه الحرس الوطني لم تتردد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في قطاع واحد ونصف في
المئه من ميزانيات جميع الوزارات
يتبع تشكيل المسلح الجديد وزاره الامن
القومي التي يراسها زعيم حزب القوه
اليهوديه اليميني المتطرف
قيل الكثير عن مهام الحرس الوطني المثير
للجدل لكن الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقول ان
الحرس سيتعامل مع حالات الطوارئ الوطنيه
مثل اضطرابات اثناء عمليه حارس الاسوار
ليس لذلك بالطبع يتوجس مسؤولون بارزون في
اسرائيل من انشاء هيئه امنيه اضافيه تاتمر
بامر
تلك التي قد يرشح لقيادتها عسكريا من تيار
الصهيونيه الدينيه
يقول يعقوب شابتاي المفتش العام للشرطه
الاسرائيليه ان الحرس القوميه خطوه غير
ضروريه مع اثمان باهظه قد تصل الى درجه
المس بالامن الشخصي للمواطنين كما قال اما
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه الاسرائيليه
غالب هارافيارا فتعارض الخطوه لوجود مانع
قانوني كما قالت ولعدم وجود حاجه امنيه
لها
[موسيقى]
لم يقتصر الرفض على المستويين الامني
والقانوني فللمعارضه السياسيه في تل ابيب
اعتراضاتها امشلا اشغال صادقه الحكومه
صباح اليوم على تقليصات ماليه لتمويل
ميليشيا خاصه
في موازنات التعليم والصحه والرفاهه
الاجتماعي والمواصلات والامن من اجل تمويل
اقامه جيش خاص من البلطجيه لبهلوان التيك
توك سلم اولويات هذه الحكومه سخيف وحقير
وكل ما يشغلها وسحق الديمقراطيه والتقدم
نحو تحقيق خيالات متطرفه لاناس مهووسين
هوسوا اثمار بنك بالقوه المسلحه التي يصر
على اطفاء طابع رسمي عليها انتهى الى صفقه
مع نتنياهو لارجاء اقرار التعديلات
القضائيه وذاك مازق المتصاعد يواجهه
ائتلاف اسرائيل الحكومي بالرغم من خطوه
تجميد المشروع وقرار الدخول في مفاوضات مع
المعارضه
تحذر المعارضه الاسرائيليه من ان مطلبها
هو الغاء التعديلات لا تاجيلها وفي سبيل
ذلك يمضي المحتجون في تكثيف الضغط على
رئيس الحكومه وشركائه من اليمين المتطرف
ومن الناصره معنا الان جاكي خوري الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا وسهلا بك في
الحصاد دعني ابدا من جزئيه التمرير
التعديلات القضائيه الى منتصف مايو والتي
تم التصريح بها
ضع هذا السجال بين الحكومه والمعارضه
مساء الخير يعني واضح ان موضوع التعديلات
المتعلقه بجهاز القضاء ما زالت موجوده
ومطروحه بقوه على الطاولات حتى لو تم
التاجيل من ناحيه التشريع بشكل مباشر في
الهيئه العامه للكنيسه ولكن النقاش الذي
يدور الان في بيت رئيس الدوله ومقر رئيس
الدوله هناك من المفروض ان تكون المفاوضات
بين الطرفين لا اعتقد انه حتى الساعه عمل
معها بجديه بمعنى ان تفضي هذه المفاوضات
الى نتيجه والى معادله وتسويه تقبل بها
الاطراف فاذا تحدثنا عن المعارضه
والائتلاف في هذه الحاله ونتحدث كما ذكرنا
سابقا وفي عده مرات عن نقاش اسرائيلي
داخلي بين يمين وسطي ويمين متطرف بالاساس
وبدل الكل يتعامل مع هذه المفاوضات بانها
ليست جديه بمعنى كل طرف لديه سقط توقعات
مختلف تماما عن الطرف الاخر وبالتالي
التقارب بين الطرفين تبدو صعبه في هذه
المرحله وعليه تادي تصريحات من قبل مثلا
اعضاء كنيست ووزراء محسوبين على الائتلاف
من جهه وفي بعض الاحيان على المعارضه وكل
طرف يحاول ان يوضح لربما لقاعدته
الانتخابيه بالاساس ما هو المقصود وما هو
الهدف من هذه
كانت على الاقل الان هو الاعلان عن الحرس
وانشاء الحرس الوطني والسؤال كيف ستتعامل
المعارضه مع هذا المعطى
اولا قبل المعارضه يجب ان نوضح قضيه مهمه
ان هذا الحرس الوطني طبعا ليس دفاعا ولا
من اجل التوضيح نتحدث الان عن تشكيل لجنه
في اسرائيل هذه
اللجنهم شخصيات محسوبه على الاجهزه
الامنيه المختلفه بما يعرف بالمستوى
المهني وحتى يخرج هذا القرار الى حيز
التنفيذ بشكل فعلي هذا بحاجه الى وقت هذه
لجنه ستعمل الان لمده ثلاثه اشهر متتاليه
حتى تقدم وترفع التوصيات لمجلس الوزراء
حول هذا الحرس الوطني كيف سيعمل وكيف
عمليا ستكون اليه العمل ميدانيا بعد ذلك
يعود الى الحكومه هنالك حاجه الى جلسه
حكومه اضافيه بعد ذلك عمليه تشريع في
الكنيست بالاضافه الى كل مساله التجنيد
وتوفير الميزانيات المطلوبه بين فير حاول
اليوم ان يظهر بشكل احتفال انه نجح في
تحقيق قرار مهم وايضا ليخدم القاعده
بالنسبه له بسبب ما يعرف الان بتنازله عن
موقف الاصلاحات وبالتالي يجب ان يكون
واضحا هذا الحرس القومي الذي يتحدثون عنه
وليس حرس سيبدا العمل خلال ايام او حتى
خلال اسابيع قليله على الاقل لدينا لها
ثلاثه اشهر من المفاوضات او من الاتصالات
الداخليه من خلال هذه اللجنه وفقط نؤكد
انه المستوى المهني في الشرطه والاجهزه
الامنيه وحتى المستشار القضائيه لحكومه
اسرائيل ترفض هذا الامر وبالتالي هنالك
شكوك كبيره حتى داخل الائتلاف ان يخرج هذا
القرار الى حيز التنفيذ ويصل الى النتيجه
التي تريد المعارضه اشكرك جاكي خوري
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا
لكم وسؤال طبيعه عمل الحرس الوطني
والوحدات التي سيتشكل منها اسئله كثيره
عنه نتابعها في هذا التقرير
فكره انشاء حرس وطني في اسرائيل بدات
تختمر منذ عامين تقريبا بعد مواجهات ايار
مايو 2021 بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
في مناطق داخل الخط الاخضر وفي يونيو
الماضي اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
انذاك نفتالي بنت ووزير الامن الداخلي
والمدير العام للشرطه يعقوب شبتاي اطلاق
الحرس الاسرائيلي الذي يعرف ايضا باسم
الحرس الوطني والذي من المفترض ان يكون
ذراعا مسانده للشرطه الاسرائيليه
وبحسب مكان مخططا ستتشكل هذه القوه من
وحدات حرس الحدود التي ستتحول لفيلق للرد
السريع مع تجنيد الاف العناصر المدربين
وهذه النقطه بدات تثير مخاوف من استقطاب
مدنيين مسلحين الى صفوفها
ويتالف الحرس الوطني من القوه النظاميه
لحرس الحدود التي تضم ثمانيه الاف مقاتل
و46 سريه احتياطيه تضم خمسه الاف مقاتل
و300 شرطي متطوع
وسيتولى الحرس الوطني القيام بمهام الرد
السريع في حاله الطوارئ تقديم استجابه
فوريه تجاه اي اضطرابات عامه والمساعده في
حالات الطوارئ والكوارث الطبيعيه
وستتيح هذه المهام للشرطه التفرغ بشكل
كامل لاداء مهامها التقليديه بحسب الخطه
الاولى لانشاء الحرس الوطني الذي من
المفترض ان يتبع هيكليا لقائد الشرطه وهنا
برزت المشكله مع الحكومه الحاليه
فوزير الامن القومي لتمر بكثير يريد للقوه
هذه ان تكون تحت امراته مباشره
واشترط اقرارها في الحكومه مقابل موافقته
على التمهل في التعديلات القضائيه وهو ما
حول المشروع الى نقطه جدليه بين الحكومه
التي يخيم عليها اقصى اليمين والمعارضه
التي ترى في حيازه بنكفير للقوه هذه
تحويلها الى ميليشيا م من مستوطنين
متشددين جاهزين للعمل بامره متطرفين
مهووسين بحسب تعبير زعيم المعارضه
ذلك اقرت الحكومه الاسرائيليه تخصيص قرابه
واحد وخمسه اعشار في المئه من ميزانيه
جميع الوزارات لتمويل الحرس الوطني الذي
سينشئ بميزانيه تصل للحو 111 مليون شيكل
تحول كميزانيه لمره واحده على ان تصل
الميزانيه السنويه لنحو واحد وستين مليون
شيكل
[موسيقى]
في تطور لافت قالت وسائل الاعلام سوريه ان
قصفا اسرائيليا استهدف قبل قليل مطار
المزه العسكري في دمشق ياتي ذلك عقب اعلان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اسقاط مسيره مجهوله
تسللت من الاراضي السوريه الى داخل
الاجواء الاسرائيليه واضاف انه تم اسقاط
المسيره في منطقه مفتوحه دون ان تشكل اي
خطر وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
تقديرات الجيش تشير الى ان المسيره
ايرانيه
وننوه بهذا الخبر الذي نقله مراسلنا عن
مصادر اسرائيليه ان الانفجار في دمشق ناجم
عن انفجار سياره ملغمه وليس هجوما
اسرائيليا
وللمزيد حتى نستوضح ماذا الجرى تحديدا
سواء في مطار المزه وما تقوله وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن الطائره المسيره
التي تفيد بانها ايرانيه الصنع هكذا تقول
استطلاعات الاوليه ينضم الينا من القدس
مراسلنا احمد هزيمه احمد اهلا بك هل من
معلومات جديده عن سواء ما حدث في دمشق او
بالنسبه للطائره التي يقول الجيش انها
ايرانيه الصنع
بالفعل ليل هناك خبران هناك حادثه هناك
اولا اختراق مسيره من الحدود الشماليه
لاسرائيل من الحدود السوريه
واسقطها الجيش بعد ان استدعى مروحيات
وطائرات مقاتله وتم اسقاطها بعد ان اخترقت
25 كيلومترا داخل الحدود الاسرائيليه
وسقطت حسب المتحدث باسم الجيش في منطقه
مفتوحه ولم تؤدي او لم يؤدي اسقاطها الى
ايه اضرار وهناك الخبر الثاني الذي ربط
اولا بهذه العمليه وهو خبر انفجارات في
قرب مطار المزه في دمشق وبنيت بالاول
روايه من ان هذا الانفجار هو قصف اسرائيلي
ردا على اسقاط المسيره التي عبرت من
الحدود السوريه لكن سرعان ما تناقلت وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه بان القوات الاسرائيليه
ليس لها علاقه بهذا الانفجار وانما هو
ناتج ربما عن سياره ملغومه انفجرت في تلك
المنطقه ونحن نعرف ليله تعودنا خلال
العمليات
الاسرائيليه او القصف الاسرائيلي المتكرر
على الاراضي السوريه ليس هناك بيان رسمي
وعاده لا يخرج الجيش الاسرائيلي اي بيان
رسمي يتعلق بهذه العمليات في الداخل
السوري وانما يكتفي فقط بالصمت وما لدينا
حتى اللحظه هو ما تداولته وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه من ان القوات الاسرائيليه او
القوات الجويه الاسرائيلي ليس لها علاقه
بالانفجار الواقع في دمشق بانتظار مزيد من
الاضاحات مزيد ربما من التسريبات مزيد من
الحديث
لفتني ما يقوله الجيش يعني في البدايه قال
انه اسقاط قطعه جويه في منطقه مفتوحه هل
تاكد انها مسيره بالفعل ولماذا استعمل هذا
المصطلح
المصطلح ربما تقني ليله عندما يتحدث الجيش
عن اجسام طائره مجهوله هذا عاده يكون
تقدير اولي من قبل ويرتبط ايضا
بمصطلحات تقنيه لدى القوات العسكريه ما
لدينا من وسائل علم اسرائيل بانها طائره
مسيره تم اسقاطها شكرا جزيلا لك احمد
هزيمه القدس
هذا وكانت وكاله الانباء الرسميه للسوريه
نقلت عن مصدر عسكريا خمسه عسكريين اصيبوا
اضافه الى وقوع خسائر ماديه نتيجه ما وصفه
المصدر بعدوان اسرائيلي بصواريخ على مواقع
في مدينه حمص وريفها وسط سوريا واضاف
المصدر ان الدفاعات الجويه السوريه اسقطت
بعض الصواريخ
ومن جهه اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل
احد مستشاريه العسكريين
برتبه نقيب ويدعى مقداد مهقاني وذلك بعد
اصابته بجروح في غاره اسرائيليه على
الضواحي العاصمه السوريه فجر الجمعه وشدد
الحرس الثوري على ان ما سماها جريمه
الكيان الصهيوني المجرم لن تمر دون رد
يذكر يذكر ان مخاني هو المستشار العسكري
الايراني الثاني الذي يقتل في الغاره على
ضواحي دمشق فجر الجمعه
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه
نصران او ناصر عفوا كنعاني قال ان الدماء
المستشارين العسكريين الايرانيين في سوريا
لن تضيع هدرا واضاف ان بلاده تحتفظ بحقها
في الرد على اسرائيل في الزمان والمكان
المناسبين ووصف كنعان استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه على سوريا بانه انتهاك
لسيادتها ووحده اراضيها واستمرار لدعم
الارهاب حسب تعبيره
وفي ظل صمت اسرائيلي رسمي بشان هذه
الهجمات قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
ان بلاده ستعمل على اخراج ايران وحزب الله
اللبناني من سوريا وانها لن تسمح لهما
بايذاء الاسرائيليين واضاف ان مكان القوات
الايرانيه وعناصر حزب الله هو ايران
مطلوب
نحن في عطر على جميع الجبهات الايرانيون
يرسلون اذرعهم الى يهودا والسامره والى
حدود لبنان والى سوريا وغزه نحن نرى ذلك
ايران تحاول ان تتمركز في سوريا وتحاول ان
تنفذ عمليات ضدنا لن نسمح للايرانيين
والعملائهم في حزب الله ان يضرون لم نسمح
بذلك سابقا ولا نسمح به في الحاضر ولا
نسمح به في المستقبل وعند اللزوم سنضربهم
وسنخرجهم من سوريا الى المكان الذي يجب
عليهم ان يكونوا فيه وهو ايران وليس هنا
الينا من تل ابيب امير اورينا الخبير في
شؤون الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اهلا بك اذا
اخذنا ما حدث الليله يعني قبل قليل فقط
تفجير في مطار مزه لا نعرف تحديدا الطبيعه
ما حصل بالضبط او بما يتعلق بالمسيره التي
تقول وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه انها
ايرانيه الصنع والتي اخترقت الاجواء
الاسرائيليه اذا ما ثبتت هذا الامر
هل يمكن القول انه تغيير في قواعد
الاشتباك الان منذ اللحظه
واحد اثنين ثلاثه
بالنسبه لاسابيع ثلاثه الماضيه اي منذ
الثالث عشر من مارس اذار حصلت زياده صعود
في التوترات في على الحدود الشماليه
الاسرائيلي من الجانب اللبناني وكذلك
الجانب السوري وكل الامر بدا طبعا باختراق
قامت قام به مخرب دخل البلاد وهو يحمل
المتفجرات معه ووضعها
وعندما استخدمها فان احد الاسرائيليين
العرب من شعبنا اصيب بجروح اسرائيل لم ترد
مباشره
ولكن من المعقول ان نفترض ان
الوتيره المتصاعده للهجمات على الاراضي
السوريه ضد الاهداف الايرانيه او اران
تعود الى الوكلاء ايران او كل هذا هو جزء
من هذه التوترات
ان هذا
المجموعه الجديده ومتجدده من قواعد
الاشتراك لابد ان ننتظر لنرى ان سنجيب على
ذلك ولكن انا رجعنا هذه من هو من يضعها
وحسن نصرله رئيس حزب الله لكن علينا ان
نلاحظ ان الايران قد تغيرت غيرت سياستها
فيما يتعلق بالاعلان عن الهجمات والضحايا
ففجاه البدوي يعترفون بان ضباطهم هم في
سوريا لم يقول لماذا ما سبب وجودهم هناك
وما يقومون به هناك هل هم ضد اسرائيل لكن
النشروا اسماء والرتبه العسكريه لهم
وبالتالي هذا يعتبر
مغادره للموقف التقليدي ياتي تصريح جالنت
بان اسرائيل مستعده لضرب سوريا يعني في
حال تطورت الامور ولكن اليس هذا ما يحصل
حاليا هو يقول ستفعل اليس هذا ما يحصل
حاليا
خلال السنوات العشره الماضيه منذ 2013
حصلت المئات من من الهجمات تقوم بها قوه
جويه اسرائيليه في الاراضي السوريه ليست
ضد اهداف السوريه بل من الواضح ان الاهداف
هي موجوده على الاراضي السوريه وهي تعود
لايران او وكلائها وغالبا ما لا تكون
تابعه لحزب الله لان هناك ردع متبادل بين
حزب الله واسرائيل
واسرائيل لا تهاجم الاهدافها في لبنان بل
حتى اذا كان هناك اشخاص لبنانيين تعرضوا
للضرر فان اسرائيل
تتجنب حصول ذلك في سوريا اذا نحن فعلا في
مرحله جديده
ولكن ما ما قاله وزير الدفاع قال انت هو
ان اسرائيل ستدفع
بايرانينا خارج سوريا وتحاول ان تعيدهم
الى حيث هو مكانهم اي الى ايران اشكرك
امير الخبير في شؤون الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي مثل ابيب
احدث الهجمات الاسرائيليه على سوريا والتي
استهدفت انطلاقا من شمال شرق بيروت مواقع
في مدينه حمص وريفها قالت رويترز ان
اهدافها قواعد جويه في المنطقه الوسطى من
البلاد يتمركز فيها جنود ايرانيون وليست
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها الحديث عن
استهداف ايران داخل سوريا وفق توصيف
الاعلام الاسرائيلي ودوائر غربيه فالهجوم
هو الثالث خلال اسبوع اذ كان اخرون طال
وفقه مواقع عسكريه للنظام السوري والقوات
المواليه لايران تشترك الغارات
الاسرائيليه على اهداف في سوريا في معظمها
في انها تتم بمقاتلات وكثير منها من نوع
اف 16 تطلق صواريخ موجهه وقذائف على اهداف
معينه في عدد كبير من الهجمات يشار الى ان
منطلقها يكون اما من الاجواء اللبنانيه
ومن الجولان او قباله السواحل السوريه
انطلاقا من البحر المتوسط اي قباله موانئ
اللاذقيه وطرطوس واللافت هنا ان المدينتين
مقر للقواعد الروسيه الجويه والبحريه في
احد النجمات على ميناء طرطوس قالت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه انه كان لوضع حد
لمحاولات ايرانيه لادخال انظمه دفاع جوي
عبر ميناء المدينه وفي فبراير شباط الماضي
وقع ثاني هجوم منذ بدايه العام استهدف
بشكل رئيسي حي كفر سوسه جنوب غربي دمشق
وبه مقرات عسكريه واستخباراتيه وافرع
امنيه افادت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه بان
شخصيه كبيره ربما كانت مستهدفه بالهجوم
وقد قتل فيه مدنيون يلفت ايضا عدم تبني
اغلب الهجمات من قبل اسرائيل ومسارعه
سوريا لاتهامها او اعلان الحرس الثوري
الايراني مقتل اعضاء منه كما حدث في اكثر
من مره خصوصا في العاصمه دمشق المطارات
هدف واضح لاستحضار مسار الهجمات في
السنوات الاخيره مره تتحدث اسرائيل عن قصف
مخزن للذخيره قرب مطار دمشق تقول انه تابع
لحزب الله واخرى تتحدث عن روايه مماثله في
مطار المزه قرب دمشق ومطار الدولي اول
هجوم اسرائيلي منذ انطلاق الثوره السوريه
وقع قرب دمشق في يناير 2013
واستهدف مجمعا عسكريا تبعه بعد اشهر
استهدفوا مركز البحوث العلميه في جمرايا
قرب العاصمه تتهم اسرائيل دمشق والطهران
بجعله مركزا لتطوير العسكري وفي 2015 قتل
سمير القنطار القيادي في حزب الله والذي
اعتقل لوقت طويل في اسرائيل في غاره
اسرائيليه بضحيه دمشق وفق الحزب في 2018
شنت اسرائيل غارات جويه واعلنت انها ضربت
اهدافا عسكريه سوريه وايرانيه وتم اسقاط
احدى طائراتها من طراز اف 16 في وقت اعلن
فيه مسؤول اسرائيلي ان الجيش شن نحو 200
ضربه خلال عام ونصف سوريا
ركزت خصوصا على اهداف ايرانيه
والاستكمال نقاشنا في هذا الملف معنى الان
من طهران الدكتور هادي اسقهي الدبلوماسي
الايراني السابق اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور اذن
هذه المستجدات الليله كيف تقيمها في اطار
الرد الايراني على اسرائيل والذي لطالما
كان الحديث عن انه متواضع ولكن الليله
الحديث عن طائره مسيره تخترق اجواء
اسرائيليه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لك التحيه ست ليلى
والمشاهدين
كان من المتوقع ان يقوم نتنياهو بهكذا
مغامرات وهو
بامس الحاجه الان اليها خصوصا في هذه
الفتره الزمنيه الحالكه التي لا يحسد
عليها نتنياهو كما جاء في تقريركم هناك
مشاكل في الحقيقه يعني يغوص فيها نتناهو
ولا يستطيع الهروب والخلاص منها الا ان
يصدر هذه الازمات الى خارج اسرائيل هذا
الموضوع الاول الموضوع الثاني هذه ليست
اول مره يرد الحرس الثوري ولكن هذه المره
سوف يحدد هو الطريقه التي يرد بها سواء
كانت من الداخل الاسرائيلي او من خارج
فلسطين المحتله باي شكل من اشكال ولا
تنزلق ايران بالتوقيت الزمني الذي الان
بحاجه اليه يتنياهو كي يو المتظاهرين
والمؤيدين له في مواجهه تهديد ايراني اذا
هناك قواعد مشتركه ست ليلى
روسيه سوريه ايرانيه حزب الله واسمه محور
المقاومه فالضربات التي يواجهها العدوان
الصهيوني وهي عمليات ارهابيه بحجه محاربه
الارهاب وهو اكبر داعم للارهاب اكثرها
تكون ضربات مدنيه او مخازن الاغذيه او
مطارات مثل مطار حلب في عز زلزال الذي
اصاب سوريا اذا ادعاءات هؤلاء في الحقيقه
منفقه ولكن فيما يتعلق بموضوع المسيره لحد
الان لم يثبت حقيقه
بصراحه دكتور هادي انت يعني ذكرت عده نقاط
واريد ان اتوقف عند عدد منها ولكن لابدا
بموضوع المسيره ان ثبت ان تتحدث عن مغامره
نتنياهو ولكن انا اسالك عن مغامره طهران
اذا ما فعلا ثبت انها ارسلت طائره مسيره
الى تخترق الاجواء الاسرائيليه الا يعتبر
هذه نقله نوعيه في طريقه الرد والى اين
تريد ان تذهب
يعني هو ليس هناك مغامرات هناك فعل وردت
فعل كما قال السيد كنعان المتحدث باسم
الوزاره خارج الايرانيه من نحن نحتفظ بحق
الرد لان كان هجوما ارهابيا على قواعد في
الحقيقه مشتركه لمحور المقاومه وعلى راسها
صاحبه الارض وهي الحكومه والقوات السوريه
هذا اولا فيما يتعلق بطبيعه الرد قبل عده
سنوات هاجمت اسرائيل قاعده شيفور ماذا
تتذكرين او يتذكر المشاهدون
كذلك هناك استشهد اربعه من قوات الحرس
المستشارين مباشره ردت ايران على قاعده
اسرائيليه في مرتفعات الجولان كانت قاعده
عسكريه وقاعده للتجسس والتصنع والتنصد
وبعدها ارسل نتناه عبر وسيط الماني لايران
انه نحن لا نريد ان نشترك معي ايران والان
يدعون انه يريدون ان يخرجوا القوات
الايرانيه الى من حيث اتوا هم الان منذ
اكثر من 11 عاما يقولون نحن نريد ان نخرج
قوات الايرانيه في حين انه هذه ذريعه لان
اساس حضورنا في سوريا هو حضور شرعي ولكن
الاعتداد الاسرائيليه حضور ارهابيه من حق
سوريا وايران ان تقابل الحكومه ما عندي
وقت كثير
تسمح لي انت ايضا اشرت لموضوع الروسي
ووجوده في سوريا لم تستعمل روسيا اي طائره
من طائره او اي سلاح ضد القصف الاسرائيلي
وكانها تبدو انها تحمي هذه اسرائيل اكثر
مما تحمي
ايران بايجاز اريد ان تعلق على هذه النقطه
انا استبعد من ان روسيا تميل الى جانب
الاسرائيلي في حين انه حتى عندما التقى
الشهيد قاسم سليماني مع المسؤولين الروس
لدعوتهم الى عام 2014 هم قالوا انه نحن
نعرف انكم انتم في حرب مع اسرائيل نار نحن
ناتي الى سوريا لمحاربه الارهاب ومنع
تقسيم سوريا لا نتدخل لا من قريب ولا من
بعيد فيما يتعلق بوضعكم مع الاسرائيليين
اذا لا احد يتوقع من الروس في الحقيقه ان
تتدخل بشكل مباشر لصالح هذا الطرف او لذلك
الطرف وهي الان متورطه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه ولا تريد في الحقيقه تثير ربما
كثير من اليهود موجودين في الداخل الروسي
وفي مناطق اخرى لا تريد اثير حساسيتهم
اشكرك دكتور هادي افقهي الدبلوماسي
الايراني السابق كنت معنا من ايران من
طهران تحديدا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلنا عدد من الدول العربيه المنضويه تحت
مظله اوبك بلس الى جانب روسيا عن تخفيض
طوعي في انتاجها النفطي وذلك اعتبارا من
شهر مايو ايار المقبل وحتى نهايه العام
الجاري في خطوه احترازيه تهدف الى دعم
استقرار اسواق النفط
جاءت قرارات الدول المصدره للنفط في
مجموعه اوبيك بلاس خفض انتاجها اليومي
متزامنه في وقت تتوقع فيه انخفاضا في
الطلب خلال الاشهر المقبله فالسعوديه
اعلنت خفض انتاجها بنصف مليون برميل يوميا
بدايه من ايار مايو الى نهايه العام وبقدر
مماثل من حجم الانتاج اعلنت روسيا خفض
انتاجها اليومي بينما اعلن العراق خفضا
ب21 الف برميل يوميا والامارات ب 144 الف
برميل يوميا اما الكويت فاعلنت خفضا بواقع
128 الف برميل يوميا بينما جاء قرار سلطنه
عمان في حدود 40 الف برميل يوميا واعلنت
الجزائر خفض انتاجها بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل
يضاف هذا الخفض في حجم الانتاج الى الخفض
الذي اعلنته مجموعه اوبك بلاس في اجتماعها
الوزاري الثالث والثلاثين شهر اكتوبر
الماضي الذي قضى حينها بتقليص حجم الانتاج
بم برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام 2023
يتوقع ان يظهر تاثير هذه القرارات في
اسواق النفط الخام بارتفاع محتمل لسعر
البرميل في المرحله المقبله وياتي ذلك
بنقيض ما تريده الولايات المتحده فقد حثت
اداره بايدن المنتجين على ضخ مزيد من
النفط في الاسواق تصف هذه الدول قراراتها
بالاجراء الاحترازي بهدف تحقيق الاستقرار
والتوازن في اسواق النفط الخام ويعتقد
محلل اسواق النفط ان اعلان القرارات جاء
هذه المره بصفه فرديه من كل دوله لتفادي
اي خلاف داخل مجموعه اوبيك بلاس فقد لا
يدعم صغار المنتجين خفضا جديدا يؤثر بشكل
كبير على موازناتهم تجدر الاشاره هنا الى
ان روسيا تواجه قرار دول مجموعه السبع
واستراليا التي فرضت في ديسمبر الماضي حدا
اقصى لسعر النفط الخام الروسي المنقول
بحرا عند 60 دولار للبرميل بهدف الحد من
ايرادات موسكو مع الحفاظ على تدفق نفطها
الى الاسواق العالميه
وتاتي قرارات مصدري النفط في ظرف اقتصادي
دولي اخر يتمثل في ازمه القطاع المصرفي في
الولايات المتحده وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
نتيجه توجهات الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي نحو رفع اسعار الفائده وذاك ما
قد يدفع الامريكيين والاوروبيين نحو سن
قواعد تنظيميه ماليه جديده
فعليا ما الذي يعنيه هذا الخفض التوعي في
انتاج النفط وكيف سينعكس على استقرار
الاسواق نقاش سنخذه بعد قليل في فقره في
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الان الى تطورات الحرف في اوكرانيا اذ
افاد موقع ريدوفكا العسكري الروسي ان قوات
فاجنر باتت في عمق مركز مدينه وانها على
بعد بضع مئات من الامتار فقط عن المبنى
الاداري للمدينه يشير الموقع الى ان قوات
باغينر تخوض معارك عنيفه جنوب غربي بخمت
وتخترق دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه تدريجيا
في المقابله اعلن نائب قائد قوات الدفاع
الاقليميه للقوات الاوكرانيه
زياده عدد قواته الى عشرات الالاف وذلك
بعد ان كان سته الاف قبل الحرب واضاف
سوبكو ان جميع وحدات قوات الدفاع
الاقليميه تمتلك خبره قتاليه وتشارك في
الهجوم المضاد في محاور بخموت ودونيتسك
في الداخل الروسيه فادت السلطات بمقتل
المراسل الحربي الموالي لروسيا ماكسيمين
في تفجير استهدفه بمقهى في مدينه سانت
بيترسبوك ونقلت وكاله التاسا الروسيه عن
السلطات ان العبوه التي انفجرت في المقهى
كانت مخبئه في تمثال تم تقديمه للمراسل
اثناء التكريم له وقالت السلطات الروسيه
ان 19 شخصا اصيبوا في التفجير كذلك
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير
طالب في اتصال هاتفيا اجراه مع نظيره
الروسي سيرجي لافروف بالافراج الفوري عن
صحفي
المعتقل في روسيا واضافت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان بلينكن بحث مع لافرف ايضا
ضروره ايجاد مناخ يسمح للبعثات
الدبلوماسيه باداء مهامها ومن جانبها اكدت
الخارجيه الروسيه
خلال الاتصال على رفض موسكو تسييس قضيه
اعتقال مراسل صحيفه
ان المراسل ضبط متلبسا وان القضاء سيحدد
مصيره
هذا وكان الجهاز امني الدوله الفيدراليه
الروسيه اعتقل اذا جرش كوفيتش مراسل
الامريكيه في منطقه الاورال واتهمه بتنفيذ
مهمه او كلتها له الولايات المتحده لجمع
معلومات عن احدى منشات التصنيع العسكري
الروسي ومحاوله الحصول على وثائق تتضمن
معلومات سريه
[موسيقى]
الى فنلندا الان التي اعلن فيها حزب
الائتلاف الوطني المعارض والذي يمثل
الجناح اليميني الفوز في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وبعد فرز نحو 94% من الاصوات
بدا ان حزب الائتلاف الوطني سيفوز بنحو
ثمانيه واربعين مقعدا من بين مقاعد
البرلمان المئتين ومن جهتها اقرت رئيسه
وزراء فنلندا سان مارين ورئيسه الحزب
الاشتراكي الديمقراطي الحاكم بالهزيمه في
الانتخابات
[تصفيق]
وينضم الان الينا من مقر حزب الائتلاف
الوطني في هيلسن مراسلنا محمد المدهون
اهلا محمد هل يمكن القول الان ان الامور
حسمت النتيجه الان واضحه
نعم اجواء احتفاليه ليلى حقيقه هنا في مقر
الحزب الذي يتقدم حتى الان بعد فرزه
تقريبا كل الاصوات
99.4% من الاصوات بيتري اوربو زعيم الحزب
يتجول بين انصاره نراه في زاويه واخرى بين
حين واخر يحتفل يبتهج هذا الانتصار الذي
كان متوقعا في استطلاعات الراي لكنه جاء
افضل من تلك الاستطلاعات حقيقه فارق خمسه
مقاعد عن الحزب الديمقراطي الاشتراكي الذي
سينصرف عن الحكم الان الحزب اليسري وبفارق
مقعدين عن حزب الفنلنديين الشعبوي اليميني
وهذا الحزب الذي ياتي في المركز الثاني
يحقق افضل نتيجه له في تاريخه
كابورا زعيمه حزب الفنلنديين اليمنيين
الشعبوي هي في صداره المرشحين من حيث عدد
الاصوات التي حصل عليها مرشح واحد حتى
انها
تخطت سنه مارينا المعروفه بالشعبيتها
الدوليه والمحليه تخطتها وحصلت على 40 الف
صوت في دائرتها الانتخابيه نعم محمد ماذا
عن اجنده الحزب فيما يتعلق بالحرب في
اوكرانيا وكيف سينعكس ذلك على انضمام
فنلندا الى النيتو
هذا حزب محافظ
يتعهد باجراءات تقشف يتعهد بانفاق اكثر
مسؤوليه كان يتهم سنه ماريم رئيسه الوزراء
التي ستكون رئيس الوزراء منصرفه عما قريب
بانها غير مسؤوله في انفاقها الذي كان
سخيا اكثر مما يجب وبالنسبه للموقف في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ويشاطرها الموقف نفسه كل الاحزاب
الفنلنديه تؤكد انها مع انضمام بلادها الى
حلف الشمال الاطلسي وانها مع الحلف الغربي
ضد ما يعتبرونه عدوانا وغزوا روسيا وربما
يكون حضور هذا الرجل فيه زياده في الانفاق
الدفاعي على حساب الانفاق على قطاعات
الرفاه الاجتماعي والتعليم والصحه لانه
تعهد باقتطاع بعض نفقات على الخدمات
العامه ربما ياخذ في حشبانه ان انفاقا
اضافيا لم يكن في حسبان الفنلنديين خلال
العقود الماضيه عندما اتخذوا موقف الحي
[موسيقى]
اولا مباشره الى نيويورك التي وضعت عناصر
شرطتها في حاله تاهب استعدادا لمثول
الرئيس السابق امام محكمه منهات الثلاثاء
المقبل وبينما نقلت وكاله السوشيت عن
مصادر مطلعه قولها
تهمه جنائيه واحده على الاقل في لائحه
الاتهام التي اقرتها هيئه محلفين قال
محاميه جو تاكو بنا ان موكله يواجه قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي لكنه يتطلع الى تبرئه موكله
تحبس نيويورك انفاسها انتظارا ليوم
الثلاثاء ففي ذلك اليوم يتعين على الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبا المثول
امام محكمه مانهاتن ومواجهه تهم على راسها
شراء صمت ممثله اباحيه عام 2016 مقابل 130
الف دولار
وفيما الاستنفار على اشده امنيا واعلاميا
نقلت وكاله السوشيت براس عن مصادر مطلعه
قولها ان ترامب يواجه تهمه جنائيه واحده
على الاقل في لائحه الاتهام التي اقرتها
هيئه محلفين في منهاتا واوضحت الوكاله ان
الرئيس السابق يواجه التهم المتعدده اخرى
بتزوير سجلات تجاريه سيكشف عنها ايضا يوم
الثلاثاء ورجح تلك المصادر ان يتم احتجاز
ترامب لكن حمله الرئيس السابق بدات واثقه
من اخلاء سبيله فقد اكدت في بيان ان ترامب
سيلقي خطابا علنيا من ولايه فلوريدا يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل بعد عودته من نيويورك
اكثر من ذلك اعلنت الحمله عن زياده هائله
في التبرعات الماليه بعد قرار الاتهام
محامي ترامب اعتبر ان موكله يواجه قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي ومع ذلك فهو يتطلع الى تبرئه
الرئيس السابق باسرع وقت ممكن
يستعد لهذه المعركه ومن الواضح انها قضيه
اضطهاد سياسي واعتقد ان الناس سواء
المعارضون له او المؤيدون يعتقدون انها
اساءه كامله لاستخدام السلطه ترامب رجل
قوي وسيكون مستعدا لهذه المعركه كما قلت
ونحن ايضا كفريق محامين جاهزون لها ونتطلع
للمضي قدما باسرع ما يمكن لتبرئته
تربى المقيم في فلوريدا يتوقع ان يمثل
امام المحكمه طواعيه ومن ثم تتلى عليه
التهم وتؤخذ بصماته وصوره له مثل ما هي
الاجراءات المتبعه ضد اي متهم انما فقط لن
توضع الاغلال في يديه وستكون تلك التدابير
سابقه اذ لم يخضع لها اي رئيس امريكي في
الماضي
ومع اقتراب اليوم الموعود يتسع الشرخ بين
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي ويشتد
الاحتقار في الشارع بين مؤيد لمحاكمه
الرئيس السابق وفقا لمبدا الا احد فوق
القانون وممدد بتلك الاجراءات بوصفها
استهدافا سياسيا لقطع الطريق امام عوده
ترامب الى البيت الابيض في انتخابات عام
وينضم الان الينا من محمد المنشاوي الكاتب
الصحفي المختص بالشان الامريكي اهلا وسهلا
بك محمد اذا يوم الثلاثاء يقترب بسرعه ما
هي السيناريوهات المحتمله
لسير هذه القضيه التي يواجه فيها
كما جاء في التقرير سيتم اخذ البصمات
والتصوير ولن يكون مقاعد اليدين وسي عليه
القاضي قائمه الاتهامات التي
تشير التقديرات الى الناس ستكون بين 20
الى 30 اتهاما وبعد ذلك سيتم اخلاء سبيل
ترامب والمحكمه ستطول ولن يكون هناك اي
احكام في القريب العاجل قد تستغرق اكثر من
عام وتدخل في في حميه او في منتصف الموسم
الانتخابي القادم الانتخابات 2024 هذا
سيناريو اذا سيناريو انه يتم اطلاق ماذا
لو لم يتم اطلاق صراحه وماذا لو كان هناك
شيء لا نعرفه الان يتضح يوم الثلاثاء
ويمثل الضروره ابقائه قيد الاحتجاز
لا اتصور ذلك
الاتهامات كلها لن لا يكون لا توجد فيها
اي اشاره الى ممارسه العنف ان يكون ترامب
قام بضرب احد او اعتاد على احد ولا نعرف
في التاريخ الامريكي اي متهم في جريمه
مدنيه لم يكون فيها استعمال العنف او سلاح
وتم حجزه بعد توجيهه الاتهامات اليه اهو
يخرج بعدها ويبدا في تشكيل فريقه القانوني
للرد على هذه الاتهامات في الموعد
المحاضره القاضي
من هنا جاء وعده بانه سيدلي بخطاب امام
انصاره في فلوريدا في نفس اليوم ولكن
اسالك محمد المنشاوي فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الجمهوري والاستقطاب الذي يحصل الان في
الشارع بين الجمهوريه والديمقراطيين هل هو
واضح المعالم ام هناك عدد كبير من
الجمهورين الان
يساندونه من باب الولاء الحزبي وهو مجرد
وقت ربما ينتهي في هذه المسانده فيما بعد
عندما يقترب الموعد الانتخابي
في الواقع ان الرئيس ترامب غير طبيعه
الحياه السياسيه خاصه في الحزب الجمهوري
تاريخيا اي اي مرشح يتعرض لاتهامات بهذه
الصوره يهاجمه كل المنافسين المحتملين له
في الانتخابات القادمه الرئيس ترامب ناله
سناء ودعم كل المنافسين المحتملين له في
الانتخابات القادمه على عكس التوقعات الكل
افترض انها ستكون فرصه كبيره للمنافسين
الاخرين مثل حاكم ولاد فلوريدا روندي
سانتوس
لكن كلهم ازاروا دعما كبيرا له وهذا هو
وما اثر به ترامب على الحياه السياسيه
الامريكيه هناك استقطاب حاد كما ذكرتي لكن
الديمقراطيون يتخوفون ايضا من ان هذه
الاتهامات وهذه الصور التي تخرج من
المحكمه ستزيد الدعم الشعبي لترامب وتؤكد
ما يكرره ان هناك استهداف له منذ وصوله
للبيت الابيض قبل سبع سنوات وان هناك
محاول تين للعزل في الكونجرس وفشله وهذه
محاوله اخرى للاقاع به
بمعنى اخر بغض النظر عن النتيجه يوم
الثلاثاء او التهمه التي توجه له فيمكن
القول ان هذه المره ايضا استفاد من هذه
الضجه التي يفترض ان تكون مسيئه له وقلب
الامور لصالحه
بلا شك
حجم التورعات لحملته تضاعف بشده خلال
الايام الماضيه وحجم الدعم الشعبي
الجمهوري حتى الان على الاقل تضاعف بشده
لا يوجد سيناريو سيخسر فيه ترامب من هذه
المواجهه القضائيه هو استفاد بالفعل
وسيستفيد مع مع الاحداث التي تتواصل بدءا
من يوم الثلاثاء القادم
في هذه الصوره
اشكرك جزيلا محمد المنشاوي المختص في
الشان الامريكي من واشنطن شكرا
[موسيقى]
ونعود الان الى ملف النفط وما اعلن عنه عن
خفض طوع في الانتاج من الدول الاعضاء في
منظمه اوبك بلس ميزان العرض والطلب اذا هو
ما يحكم قرارات هذه الدول في خفض انتاجها
من النفط طوعيا بمعنى اخر فان القرار
بالمبدا وبمعزل عن سياقاته الاخرى يعني
حصرا ارتفاعا مقبلا في اسعار النفط الخام
والمشتقات البتروليه الغرض من ذلك هو وقف
هبوط الاسعار الذي شهدته الاسواق خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه هكذا اعلن هذا الهبوط
احاله مندوبون في اوبك بلس قبل اسبوعين
الى مخاوف من ازمات ماليه عالميه في اشاره
طبعا الى ازمه المصارف وليس الى خلل في
ميزان الطلب والامداد
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه عولت المجموعه
النفطيه على زياده متوقعه في الطلب الصيني
تحديدا للنفط لاعاده التوازن الى السوق
لكنها ابقت الباب مواربا على اتخاذ
اجراءات اخرى ما لم يحدث هذا التوازن وهو
طبعا الامر الذي شهدناه اليوم
هذا القرار اذا اثار حفيظه الدول خارج
منظمه الاوبك مثلا الولايات المتحده وهي
واحده من اكثر الدول استهلاكا للنفط حول
العالم تستهلك ما يقرب من تسعه عشر مليونا
وستمائه الف برميل نصف سنويا اي بمعدل 20%
من الحصه العالميه
الصين تبلغ حصتها ما يزيد عن 12 مليون
و700 الف برميل من النفط سنويا
وتوقعت كما ذكرنا قبل قليل ان يرتفع طلب
بيجين على النفط هذا العام
يرتفع بسبع مئه الف برميل يوميا
[موسيقى]
في المركز الثالث تاتي الهند والتي تستهلك
قرابه اربعه ملايين واربعمائه الف برميل
من النفط سنويا تليها اليابان
وذلك بمعدل استهلاك يفوق اربعه ملايين
برميل من النفط سنويا
كوريا الجنوبيه يبلغ استهلاكها السنوي من
النفط نحو مليونين و600 الف برميل من النص
اذا هذه الخطوه هي ما سنناقشها مع ضيفنا
من لندن الدكتور مصطفى البازرقان الخبير
في شؤون النفط والطاقه اهلا وسهلا بك في
الحساد وابدا معك من هذه الخطوه نحاول ان
نفهمها ما الذي يعنيه الخفض الطوعي لهذه
المجموعه في من الدول في الاوبك بلس
بدايه يعني تاثير على اسعار النفط هذه
نقطه النقطه الثانيه الطوعي بمعنى تركت
للمجموعه وللدول المشاركه في هذا الخف
كيفيه الخفض والفتره الزمنيه والمستوى
التي تصل اليه ولكن هذا جميعه لا يمنع انه
هذا القرار كان مفاجئا لماذا لانه هذا
القرار لو اتخذ قبل ثلاثه اسابيع كانت
هناك موجه بتراجع اسعار النفط ولكن
الاسباب كانت اولا كان هناك ازمه مصرفيه
بدات صناديق التحوط ببيع النفط وبالتالي
عوده تراجع الى مستويات 72 دولار ولكن لحد
يوم الجمعه الماضي وصلت الاسعار النفط الى
قاربه الثمانين دولارا وكانت باستمرار
الارتفاع ولذلك يشاهدنا هذه المفاجاه في
هذا القرار بالذات ولذلك انا اعتقد انه
منذ صباح يوم غد في في اس يكون هناك قفزه
في اسعار النفط ولكن هذا سياخذنا الى
مائيه تاثيرات وتداعيات هذا القرار على
الاقتصاد العالم قبل ان نتكلم عن
تداعياتها اريد ان اسالك يعني في الاسباب
التي اعلنت هي استقرار الاسواق العالميه
هذا هو السبب المعلن ولكن اريد ان اسالك
عن السبب غير المعلن الذي جعل هذه الدول
تقدم على هذه الخطوه المفاجئه كما وصفتها
خصوصا وان المتوقع وهناك تقارير تقول ان
اسواق النفس سيرتفع اصلا
قد يكون استخدم كلمه مبرر لهذا الخفض وهي
انه غالبيه ميزانيات الدول وضعت اسعار
النفط بين السبعين الى 80 دولار فمن اجل
المحافظه على مستوى سعر معين لابد انه
تكون اسعار نص بهذا بهذا المدى ولكن من
الواضح انه كانت الاسعار نفسها ترتفع ولكن
هذا القرار المفاجئ خاصه حينما نعلم انه
مسؤولين او قبل عشره ايام رفضوا اي اقتراح
الولايات المتحده
والالتزام
بقرارات اوبك لحد نهايه هذا العام فجاء
هذا هذا هذا القرار هذه النقطه النقطه
الثانيه يوم الجمعه الماضي من حسن الصدف
ان صح التعبير كان هناك تقرير لوكاله
الطاقه الدوليه حددت انه سيكون هناك في
منتصف هذا هذا الربع الذي بدا يوم امس
سيكون هناك الطلب سيتخطى
المعروض وهذا وكانما لديها بعد نظر بهذا
القرار الذي بالتاكيد سيؤثر على المعروضه
بالتالي سيكون الطريق بما انه لم يبقى
لدقيقه الا دقيقه ما الذي سيكون تاثيره
علينا نحن يعني الذين نتابع كل ما يجري
ماذا سيكون تاثيره على المواطن
ان كان طبعا تاثيره على المواطن في الدول
المنتجه لنفسه يكون هناك ارتفاع سنشهد
خلال الايام القادمه الاسبوع القادم قد
ترتفع اكثر من ثمانيه دولار ولكن سنرى
هناك ردود فعل ردود فعل اقتصاديه من جانب
العالم خاصه نحن العالم ان هناك ازمه
ماليه هناك تضخم وايضا هناك ردود فعل
سياسيه قد نشدها خلال الايام القادمه اما
بالنسبه للغرب فهذا بالتاكيد يؤثر على
المواطن الذي يعيش في الغرب بزياده اسعار
الطاقه اشكرك جزيلا مصطفى البازكان الخبير
الاقتصادي كنت معنا اذا من لندن
شكرا
[موسيقى]
اذا بهذا نصل الى نهايه جوله الحصاد
الليله نتحول بكم الى الاعزاء عبد القادر
ووسيله وجوله منتصف الليل